Bon, alors?
Je comprends pas ce que t’attends de moi.
Tu m’avais pas dit que tu connaissais les marais comme ta poche?
Si, mais là…
Je t’offre le plus  grand coup de toute ta vie bon sang.
90000 pièces d’or, réfléchis!
Mais tu préfères peut-être crever ici,
et passer tes journées et tes nuits entières à servir du rhum et éponger du vomis
comme ton vieux taré de connard de père.
Eh, ho!
C’est juste que tu sais pas dans quoi tu t’embarques là
Tout ce dont je suis sûr, c’est que cette carte est capable de nous mener à un coffre.
On a la carte,
on trouve le coffre
et à nous le magot.
Mais arrête on y comprend rien c’est du charabia ton truc!
C’est rédigé sur une espèce de peau de chamois qui daube,
y’a des signes sataniques dans tous les coins,
c’est écrit dans une langue …
j’connais même pas!
Y’a des énigmes, y’a des rébus,
y’a un sudoku putain!
Pourtant j’en ai vu des cartes,
mais des comme ça, jamais.
Moi j’en ai vu une!
Dis-moi tout ce que tu sais vieil homme.
Vous n’avez pas la moindre idée du pétrin dans lequel vous venez de vous fourrer.
J’ai passé la moitié de ma chienne de vie à chercher ce foutu coffre.
J’pensais y trouver un trésor,
j’ai perdu ma main!
Et un œil.
Ah non, ça c’est en faisant du cheval j’me suis pris une branche.
Et tu pourrais traduire ça?
C’est un dialecte secret utilisé par les esclaves des caravelles
lors des grandes mutineries du vieux royaume.
Une langue abrupte au palais mais très douce à l’oreille
issue de la culture elfique et...
fortement inspirée du slave.
Et ça dit quoi?
Eh bah ça …
je sais pas.
Moi je sais!
De grande bravoure tu sauras faire preuve,
car de tes seules mains nues,
tu devras tuer la grande pieuvre.
Quoi?
Bon, après j’adapte à ma sauce pour faire en sorte que ça rime hein.
Ça se trouve c’est un phoque ou une raie.
Tu peux le traduire ce texte oui ou merdre?
-Oui mais bon …
Mous maria, c’est marin,
Atravius c’est mains nues,
faudra flinguer un truc à mains nues.
Après savoir si c’est une baleine ou une méduse…
j’peux pas vous dire.
Moi je peux!
J’te préviens j’suis pas d’humeur alors accouche.
Ohhh t’inquiete pas pour ça gamin, je n’vais pas m’éterniser.
Mais,
j’me sens obligé de t’filer un ptit coup de pouce.
Parce que l’animal auquel tu devras te confronter
n’a ni la douceur de l’orque,
ni la délicatesse de l’alligator.
Crois-en mon expérience.
J’t’écoute.
Est-ce que tu sais à quoi ressemble un Mégalodon?
Nan
-Moi je sais!
Nan, euh… pardon…
C’est parce que je …
Nan mais c’est bon continuez
C’est une créature préhistorique absolument titanesque
qui hante encore de nos jours les abysses du nord de Pangolia.
C’est comme...
un gros requin.
Voilà.
Faudra que tu tues un très,
très très,
très très très,
très gros requin.
Et on un fait comment? Il a …  il a un point faible... ?
Alors ça mon p’tit bonhomme, j’en ai pas la moindre idée.
Moi j’en ai la moindre idée!
Si vous chercher un chasseur, j’suis votre homme.
J’ai par le passé capturé plus d’un centaure,
j’ai dormi avec une douzaine d’ours,
j’ai mordu un panda jusqu’au sang,
j’ai jonglé avec des renards,
j’ai mangé de la dinde
et même récemment, j’ai étranglé un tout p’tit  dragon
Oh! Un bébé?
Ouais un bébé ouais.
Oh merde.
Bah, il a essayé d’me niaquer c’t’enculer.
BREF!
Donnez moi jusqu’à demain et j’vous dirais tout ce qu’il y a savoir sur cette saloperie de poiscaille.
J’ai tout noté chez moi dans un joli p’tit calepin.
Bah le truc c’est qu’il faudrait que je sache maintenant.
Oui, bah moi j’peux pas aller plus vite.
Moi je peux!
Et à vrai dire, j’peux carrément vous accompagner.
Par contre j’ai pas de bateau.
Moi j’en ai un!
Un voilier d’une trentaine de mètres seulement,
mais entièrement refait à neuf.
Avec coin cuisine, salle de bain,
trois chambres et toilettes séparées.
Heu par contre, pensez à prendre un duvet,
parce que … j’en ai pas.
Moi j’ai un duvet!
Et je sais aussi où se cache la moitié de la carte.
Ça m’étonnerait!
L’autre moitié a périe dans le grand incendie des deux tourelles à la fin du siècle dernier.
Personne n’a jamais su qu’elle secret elle renfermait.
Moi je sais!
Mon père, son père et le père du père de mon père
l’on mémorisé et m’ont transmis ses secrets quand j’étais gosse.
J’peux vous la dessiner comme ça, de tête.
Par contre j’ai pas de crayon.
Moi j’en ai un!
Par contre il marche pas très bien.
Moi j’ai un crayon qui marche bien!
Par contre personne n’aurait du feu?
Si, moi j’en ai!
Ah non apparemment j’ai plus d’essence...
STOOOOP!
En gros tout le monde a un avis sur tout et n’importe quoi mais il manque ceci cela …
Faut que j’bute un truc,
je sais pas quoi…
J’dois creuser,
je sais même pas où.
Il me manque la moitié de la carte…
Y’a un moment faut arrêter les conneries.
Faut se rendre à l’évidence…
J’le trouverais jamais ce trésor.
Moi j’lai déjà trouvé!